PETE LEPAGE: Welcome, everybody,
to another edition
of our "Chrome Apps Office
Hours." We've got a really
great show today with a special
guest joining us from
Mountain View.
John McCutchan is going to be
talking about using Native
Client and Acceleration Modules
within Chrome Apps.
So really allowing you to take
a whole bunch of the stuff
that you're used to being able
to do with Native Client and
put that into a Chrome app.
So, with that, John, I'll
turn it over to you.
I'll let you introduce yourself
and talk about Chrome
Apps a little bit.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Hey, everyone.
I'm John McCutchan, and I work
on the Native Client team as a
developer programs engineer.
And today I'm going to talk
about how you can really
accelerate the performance
inside your Chrome Apps.
So what are Chrome
Packaged Apps?
I've taken this text snippet
here straight off of the
Chrome Apps developer website.
And it says that "Chrome apps
deliver an experience as
capable as a native app but
as safe as a web page.
They're built with open web
technologies, like HTML5,
JavaScript, and CSS.
But they look and behave
like native apps.
And they also have native-like
capabilities." And in the
lower right hand corner of the
slide, you can see a screen
shot of a Chrome Packaged App,
which is launching from the
Start menu, and looks and feels
just like a native app.
But the question remains is,
how do they perform?
Do they offer native
performance, which you come to
expect if something is
a native application?
Let's quickly run through
and see how some
common algorithms perform.
So right here we're looking
at a graph showing the
performance of C++ Bullet
Physics engine, which is a 3D
physics engine which has been
used in many AAA video games.
Compared to the JavaScript
performance of the same
library, that would--
you can't really see the native
C++ performance on this
graph because it's just
so much faster.
But let me zoom in.
So you can start to see a
clearer picture here.
We're seeing something that
looks like maybe 10 or 100
times slower performance from
the JavaScript side
than the C++ side.
And if we switch over and we
look at GZIP decompression
timings, again, we see
the same story.
Native performance is remarkably
fast compared to
the JavaScript equivalent.
And again, we see that with the
GZIP compression timings.
What's interesting here is that
it's remarkable to me
that you can do this
in JavaScript.
But you can still do it so
much faster outside of
JavaScript.
So how do these Chrome Packaged
Apps perform?
Well, JavaScript applications
are, on average, in order of
magnitude, slower than
native applications.
So while Chrome Apps are going
to give us these native feel
and functionality applications,
they just can't
overcome the performance gap
between JavaScript and C++
without some help.
So what if we could have the
best of both worlds?
A world where we have native
performance where we really
need it, but we get to write
the majority of the
application in JavaScript.
That's exactly what Native
Client Acceleration
Modules give you.
You have 90% of your application
written in
JavaScript.
This allows your development
to be really flexible.
You can do your UI
in JavaScript.
Very fast iteration times.
It's a great developer
experience.
Well, the remaining 10%, the 10%
of your application where
performance really matters, can
be written in C++, often
using off-the-shelf libraries
that are already written for
you that you just have to go
and expose to JavaScript.
C++ gives you performance.
You can reuse existing code.
And these modules are reusable
across many applications.
You can imagine how many
applications could benefit
from fast decompression or
compression algorithms.
So Native Client Acceleration
Modules combined with Chrome
Apps gives you 90% of Chrome App
but the native performance
where you really need it.
So what are Native Client
Acceleration Modules?
Simply put, they expose C++
libraries to the web.
They're Native Client programs
that are designed to
communicate with JavaScript.
They have no user interface
at all.
They are effectively
libraries.
And they're a combination
of C++ and JavaScript.
So for those of you don't know,
what is Native Client?
Well, it's a secure
C/C++ runtime and
toolchain for the web.
It runs existing C/C++
and C# code natively.
It's completely secure.
It's sandboxed.
It's safe.
And it's available within
Chrome today.
What I'm hoping a lot of the
Chrome App developers don't
already know is that you can
actually use Native Client in
combination with your
Chrome Apps.
And Native Client interacts with
Chrome through a Pepper
API, which exposes all sorts of
functionality, like OpenGL,
Gamepad support, Mouse Lock,
Full Screen, et cetera.
PETE LEPAGE: For folks who don't
know, what is Pepper?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Pepper is a
plug-in interface to Chrome.
And it exposes functionality to
plug-ins that Chrome hosts.
So Chrome hosts an OpenGL,
a Gamepad library, some
functionality to go
full screen and
come out of full screen.
And plug-ins can access that.
Native Client Modules are
effectively sitting on top of
the Pepper plug-in interface.
So that's how they implement
their functionality that
depends on Chrome.
PETE LEPAGE: OK, cool.
So you've got Native Client
that interacts with the
Pepper, so that way it's an easy
way for developers to get
access to these things?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, yes.
It's very secure, very safe.
So if you wanted to develop a
Native Client application,
what's the workflow
look like, then?
You take your C++ code.
You run it through the Native
Client compiler,
which is just GCC.
And the output of that is a
Native Client EXE and a
manifest file.
The manifest file describes some
dependencies that your
application has and any
other requirements.
And then you just insert
an embed tag into your
HTML, and that's it.
You go from a fully functional
C++ program that is running
securely at native performance
inside of Chrome.
It accesses things like OpenGL
through the Pepper API.
So you can see a screen shot
here of AirMech, which is a
fully C++ game.
So what are Native Client
Acceleration Modules?
Because what I'm not really
suggesting here is that you
write an entire Chrome
app in C++.
What I'm saying is that you
extract the useful performance
pieces of C++ and expose that
to JavaScript so that your
Chrome application can offload
some of the really
performance-intensive
work to C++.
So the high-level view
looks like this.
On the left, we have the
Chrome application.
Then we have a Native Client
Acceleration Module JavaScript
layer, which exposes the API
to the Chrome application,
some kind of message-passing
magic.
And then on the C++ side, a
Native Client Module that
knows how to communicate with
the JavaScript pair on the
other side.
PETE LEPAGE: Now, John, I assume
you're going to tell us
where that magic comes from,
and that I don't have to go
figure that out myself.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes, yes.
Later on in the talk, I'm going
to talk about a library
that I've written that makes
this really easy.
So you just have to handle
the messages.
And all the plumbing is
taken care of for you.
So I want to switch gears.
PETE LEPAGE: We can just get
everything back and forth.
Sorry.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No, no.
Please feel free to
interrupt me.
So I want to switch gears and
show a demo off here.
What I'm going to show is
Bullet Physics, which is
running in C++, combined
with a front end as
it's written in three.js.
All of this is sitting inside
of a Chrome app.
So here I am.
Everything being drawn here
has been expressed in
JavaScript or HTML.
And if I start up the
simulation, you can see here
that I've got a Jenga pile.
Let me switch to
maybe 10 rows.
I can pick up an object
and start playing with
it and move it around.
Let me move the screen.
You can see that there's a
simulation time counter.
And this is just reporting how
long it takes the C++ code to
update the physics simulation.
And right now we're looking at
about 100, 150 microseconds.
If I switch over to 400 cubes,
that's going to go up.
It's approaching three
to four milliseconds.
Now keep in mind that the same
program executing in
JavaScript is an order
of magnitude slower.
So we've been able to couple
high-performance C++ physics
simulations with an interactive
JavaScript
application sitting inside
of a Chrome app.
Interactive to the point where
I can grab objects, zoom in
and zoom out, pick them
up, move them
around, play with them.
It's all running at 60 hertz,
something that's just not
possible in an application
entirely written in
JavaScript.
I have a blog post on my
website, which we'll link to
after the show, which actually
describes a file format where
you can write your own scenes
and then load them into the
application.
So it's kind of a fun little
physics playground.
So let's play a game.
What part of that was written
in JavaScript?
And what part of that
was written in C++?
So the main loop, JavaScript.
Rendering, JavaScript.
Object selection, determining
the rigid body that's under my
mouse cursor, JavaScript.
Physics simulation, C++.
And scene loading is
a combination of
JavaScript and C++.
The JavaScript side is
responsible for parsing the
input file and structuring it
in such a way that the C++
program expects,
but that's it.
So it's kind of interesting.
We get this hyper fast
physics simulation.
But most of our application
was written in JavaScript.
So it's very fun to
play around with.
So how does this demo work
at a really high level?
Well, in the blue boxes we have
messages that are passed.
And the arrows are expressing
which direction they're going
in, with the C++ module
being on the right.
So at the initialization phase,
a load scene message is
sent to C++, which describes
the scene, describes the
initial state of the rigid
bodies, and their shapes, and
things like that.
And that gets sent over to the
C++ module, which then
actually loads the scene into
the Bullet Physics simulation.
Then at a regular interval, the
JavaScript code sends a
message over to C++ that says,
run the physics simulation,
update where the objects are,
and report back to me when
you're done.
So these are running in
parallel, actually.
While the physics simulation is
executing, Chrome and your
JavaScript application are
off doing something else.
It's running a separate thread,
taking advantage of
the many cores that
we all have.
PETE LEPAGE: That's a real big
advantage, too, because you're
not necessarily going to block
the UI thread in order to do
any of that processing, which
sometimes happens with
applications when you're doing
complex JavaScript.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah, I mean
that's why we have web
workers, right?
Web workers allow you to offload
this heavy work in a
way that doesn't block
the UI thread.
Native Client Acceleration
models work in the same way.
You could think of them
as almost like a web
worker, in a way.
But it just happens to be
running C++ code and not
JavaScript.
But just like with
web workers.
You communicate through
message passing.
You communicate with a Native
Client Acceleration model
through message passing.
So after this step simulation
event is delivered, the
physics simulation thread wakes
up, runs its processing,
and then spits back out a
Float32Array containing the
positions and orientations
of all the rigid
bodies in the scene.
The JavaScript code takes that
array and parses it and
updates the rendering position
of all objects.
And this just loops, as any
interactive application does.
So what if you wanted to build
your own Native Client
Acceleration Module?
I'm going to leave some of the
details out of this, but this
is going to paint the high level
picture and give you a
lot of pointers to where
to look if you want to
really get into it.
So building a Native Client
Acceleration Module consists
of three main components.
The first is you have to write
your C++ glue layer that takes
the messages and passes them
to the C++ code that you
already have written or you've
downloaded off the web.
You have to write a twin of that
on the JavaScript side,
which receives messages from C++
and also packages messages
up to send to C++.
And then you have to determine
what messages you want to send
between the two worlds and what
data should be included
in each one.
So to make this really easy,
I've created a pair of
libraries called Native Client
Acceleration Module Base library.
It's a C++ library and a
JavaScript library that makes
creating acceleration modules
incredibly easy.
You just have to write the code
that responds to messages.
You don't have to worry about
how do messages get across?
How do I queue them up?
All you have to do is just
implement a call back that
says, hey, I got this
type of message.
What should I do?
You implement that little bit
of logic, and the rest is
taken care for you in the
most performant way.
So let's talk about the
structure of the messages.
So messages are split
into a header and
then optional frames.
The header is just a JSON
object, which has a command
name, a request ID, which is
just the unique ID of this
specific request, and then a
frames count, which is either
0 if there's no auxiliary
frames, or some positive
integer expressing the frames.
You can see the structure
of the message on
the right hand side.
The JSON message header
is always present.
And that's in red.
The frames in blue
are optional.
And these frames are interpreted
entirely by your
message handler.
They're just a bag of either
strings or raw
bytes in a byte array.
The Native Client Source Model
base library doesn't know
what's in these at all.
It just knows how to collect
them and aggregate them into
the larger meta message.
So coming back to the Bullet
Physics demo, this is the
messages that we've defined.
So JavaScript can send a load
scene message to C++.
It can send a step scene
message to C++.
And it can also send a pick
up or drop object message.
You saw that I was picking the
objects, and I said that the
selection was being done
in JavaScript,
which is entirely true.
The JavaScript code figures out
what's under your mouse
cursor and then sends that index
over to the C++ world
and says, physics simulation,
grab that object, and pretend
that I'm holding it.
Inside the step scene message
is the position of my mouse
cursor at the time.
So that's how I'm able to
interactively play with the
physics object while the
scene is simulating.
Finally, there's one message
that comes from C++ to
JavaScript.
And that's the scene update
message, which includes the
updated position and
orientation of
all the rigid bodies.
On the C++ side, a Native Client
Acceleration Module
based library requires that you
implement just three functions.
One is an initialization
routine, which just includes
all your module start
up stuff.
This is just going to be called
automatically when your
Acceleration Module is
first initialized.
There is a heartbeat method
which you can implement, which
just gets called at 60 hertz.
So if you have to do anything
regularly inside of your
acceleration module, this is
where you put that logic.
And then finally, the handle
message callback, which is
called whenever a message is
delivered from JavaScript.
And this is where you put your
application-specific logic,
which is like, hey, I just
got a step scene message.
Let me go and trigger the
physics simulation thread and
let it run.
You don't have to worry about
packaging up messages or
parsing them in any way.
You just have to implement
the logic.
On the JavaScript side,
it's really natural.
If you want to respond to
something like, hey, the scene
was updated, you just go
Add Event Listener.
Or when you're done, you could
go Remove Event Listener.
So from the JavaScript
programmer's prospective, this
feels very natural.
An Acceleration Module is just
some element that you can add
an event listener to.
And the events are the
messages coming
from the C++ module.
And if you want to send a
message to C++, there's a
single method, Send Message,
which just takes the command
name and some frames.
It's very straightforward.
I'm calling out in grey to scene
NaClAM.js At the end of
the talk, there will be a link
to the GitHub repository,
which includes this library.
And you can dig in from there.
So wrapping up, NaCl
acceleration models bring
native performance to web
applications and Chrome
applications.
It's really straightforward to
use if you're a web developer.
And, like I said, you get 90%
of your application as a
Chrome app written in JavaScript
and HTML5.
And that last 10% where the
performance really matters,
you get from C++.
And you get native performance,
in order of
magnitude faster than what's
possible through JavaScript.
So hopefully you're really
interested in this.
You want to get involved.
So the first step to building
a Native Client Acceleration
Module is to go and grab the
Native Client SDK from
gonacl.com.
You can try out the Bullet
Physics demo by going to the
link on the slide.
And you can join the Native
Client discussion thread by
going to the final link
on the slide.
After you've gotten the SDK
running, you can go and grab
the NaClAMBase framework
from the GitHub
repository on the slide.
And this includes the complete
source code to the Bullet
Physics demo that
I demonstrated.
So you can build that yourself
and play around with it and
add new features.
It's a great place to start.
So included inside the base
repository are three example
Native Client Acceleration
Modules--
the Bullet Physics one; an image
processing one, which
takes a set of pixels from a
canvas object, does something
with it, and then sends it back
over to JavaScript and it
gets displayed again; and
then a Zlib compress
and decompress module.
These are just example modules
that you may use as a jumping
off point or just as a template
to create your own
and expose new libraries that
I haven't exposed yet.
So Chrome Apps plus Native
Client Acceleration Modules
give you native performance
where it counts, which is
really exciting, because Chrome
Apps already offer
native feeling and native
functionality with them.
But it's just missing that
final piece, which is
performance.
Luckily, though, most
applications only need
performance in a very small
chunk of their code.
And this is where Native
Client Acceleration
Modules come in.
Again, 90% of your application
is written
increase in Chrome Apps.
The last little bit
is written in C++.
So time for questions.
But make sure you follow
me on Twitter.
You can check out my blog
or read my code.
And if there's a Native Client
Acceleration Module that you
really want exposed, and maybe
you're not the greatest C++
programmer, hit me up on G+.
And if it's a good idea, I'll
be happy to do it for you.
PETE LEPAGE: Cool.
Well, thanks, John.
That's some pretty neat stuff.
And I think not only is it good
for things where you're
just really trying to
improve performance.
But it's really good for when
you've got to do stuff that's
maybe complex or you've already
got libraries written
in other languages, where you
just want to be able to reuse
that across applications.
One company I was talking to
a couple of weeks ago was
saying, look, we have this
really great sync library that
we use in our native
apps for mobile.
And we really want to be able to
use that sync library to be
able to sync data between the
client and the application.
This is a perfect solution for
them to be able to do that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
I think you really hit the nail
on the head when you said
you have this existing
code base.
A lot of applications that are
interested in coming to the
web, they already have a large
part of their application
written in C++ or some
other language.
And so the only thing that you
have to add on here is this
message-passing logic.
PETE LEPAGE: Yep.
Cool.
Well, why don't we take some of
the questions that people
have posted to our Google
Moderator, and I'll have a
look at some of the YouTube
questions as well.
But Max West wants to know, "can
NaCl Acceleration Modules
be used to encrypt streaming
files, like media, audio,
video, and that kind
of thing?"
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Absolutely.
And there's another talk which
we'll link to afterwards which
includes a measurement of the
latency in the throughput of
transmitting data.
And the throughput right now
is about 400 megabytes per
second on my machine.
So that's round trip.
So that's from JavaScript into
Native Client Acceleration
Module and then back into
JavaScript at 400 megabytes
per second.
PETE LEPAGE: That's
pretty serious.
I'm trying to think what
you'd need for video.
But I'd be willing to bet that's
probably pretty close,
if not good enough.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Back of the
envelope, I think you can do a
1024 uncompressed image with 32
bits per pixel at 60 hertz.
And that's about 260 megs.
So you still some
room left over.
And of course, when you're
dealing with video, it's
already compressed.
PETE LEPAGE: Right.
Yeah, that's true.
All right.
Next, Rob from Missoula wants
to know, "is it possible to
compile existing libraries
written in C# or Java to be
used in NaCl in a Chrome app?"
And I know you touched on C#
and said that the
answer was yes.
But what about Java?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I don't know
if that's possible today.
But C# absolutely does work.
PETE LEPAGE: So you said to
compile the stuff, people need
to grab their GCC compiler.
Where can they find
the great--
I just want to go
through this.
Are the docs up on the Chrome
Developer website?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So for Native
Client, you want to go to
gonacl.com.
And that's going to explain
everything you need to know
about developing with
Native Client.
And right now, for Native Client
Acceleration Modules,
the best place is to hit up the
GitHub repository, which
has a lot of example code.
We're going to be working to add
some stuff to the Chrome
Apps documentation.
PETE LEPAGE: And that's
on the GitHub
repository that you posted?
Or is that in the Google Chrome
GitHub repository?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's in my
own GitHub repository.
And we'll post a link after
the show as well.
PETE LEPAGE: OK.
We'll get a post up on our
Chrome Developers page that
you can go and have a look at.
GT from India wants to know
whether the media source
extension APIs are going to be
supported with Chrome for
Android beta or the latest?
We're not really focusing on
some of the Chrome for Android
stuff today.
But that's something that I
believe we want to support.
But I don't want to give you a
complete answer right now, GT,
because I'm not actually 100%
sure on the answer there.
And then, John, last one for
you, and then we'll sign off.
But "when will we be able to
have multiple OpenGL contacts
in NaCl and use them off
the main thread?"
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So calling
off of the main
thread is coming soon.
I'm not entirely sure on
the specific Chrome
and NaCl SDK release.
But it's coming really soon with
the ability to make all
sorts of Pepper calls off
of the main thread.
With respect to multiple OpenGL
contacts, I am not sure
when that is coming,
PETE LEPAGE: All right.
Well, cool.
Thanks for those answers.
And thanks for a really
interesting
presentation today.
I didn't realize how this could
solve a lot of problems
for people who already have
existing code bases, or maybe
who are looking for places where
they just want to get
that a little bit of extra
performance that they can't
get because JavaScript V8 is
fast but maybe isn't quite
where they need it to be in
order to do some rather
complex calculations.
Thanks for joining us.
And thanks to everybody for
watching this week.
We'll be back next week.
I'll be live from
Mountain View.
And we'll have Paul
Kinlan joining me.
We're going to do just a fun--
we're not going to plan
a topic for next week.
We want to take your
questions.
We want to open it up
to you to just chat.
We're going to show off
some really cool
demos, some neat stuff.
I think I've got one up my
sleeve that hopefully I'll be
able to get some stuff done
before then so that you guys
can go and check out some
really cool stuff.
Thanks for joining us, John.
Thank you very much.
And Louis, thanks
for producing.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Thanks,
everyone.
PETE LEPAGE: And have a
great week, everybody.
Thank you.